have a look at this okay what I'm going
to do is going to put some constructions
up in this new circle that we've created
a zdy
writes a new circle so watch this I'm
gonna join up ad can you join up ad on
your diagram once you join up ad watch
carefully I'm just gonna zoom in here
just so you can focus on this particular
circle okay when you join up ad you form
this angle a D Z let me even color it in
so it's a little more obvious there's a
DZ over there
okay but there's an eagle standing on
the same arc as that do you notice it
standing on the same arc as a Z this guy
over here you've also got a whyzard in
the corner see that guy there
ad Zed equals a Y zero for the reason we
were just mentioning that angles
standing on the same arc over here they
extend out this way and they extend out
that way and Y and D are both on the
circumference of the same circle that's
why I bothered to prove that they are
concise look okay all right
good that's progress now I also asked
you to look at CD X&Y c d x and y how
can I prove that those guys are concise
like have a look have a think can you
see it I'm going to use exactly the same
property I just use yes there again
which are you talking about dy
okay let me help you out often before
you prove that something is true this is
an overall principle in geometry before
you prove something is true it might
help to imagine that it's true and then
see what would result so let's just
imagine that I have this let's change
the color because I already have a blue
circle let's imagine I already know that
CD and x and y are all the same circle
that circle would look something like
this this is trickier than it looks
how's that it's a bit fat right let's
change that there we go that's that's
reasonable isn't it does that go through
CD X&Y it's pretty close right okay now
do you see if that really is a circle
then you should be expecting that some
angles are standing on the same arc and
they should be equal can you see any
angles standing on the same arc that are
equal they're even already marked in
okay you see let me highlight it for you
I'll highlight in orange can you see D Y
C can you actually see that mark you can
right do I see that's 90 degrees right
what's it equal to what's the other
90-degree angle in there yeah D X C you
see that
so those remember I haven't proved that
it's a circle yet I'm about to NAT 10
seconds those angles are equal and
they're sabai
here's the arc that they stand on so
since those angles are equal they must
be on and on and on the circumference of
a circle okay so now I've shown that
there is an orange circle let me get rid
of the highlight now because it's a bit
overkill
there is an orange circle C D X and why
because of these angles are the same
segments being equal okay
all right we're so close and it's good
because the bells about to go we're
always there what's this X Y see see
this guy in here I'm just going to color
that in there's an angle standing on the
same segment key but I haven't drawn it
well let me
quickly for you CD if you join up can
you join up CD now do you notice that
these guys are both standing on the same
ark what are they standing on you can
name it XC very good it's down it's down
here right can you see both those orange
angles standing on this Ark down here
you can see it right it's extending up
okay
so therefore I've got those to be equal
okay now watch watch this I'm gonna go
pick up one last color okay let's call
this angle here theta
can you name it feet up on there tell me
the size of d CX d CX d CX over there in
the corner 90 - theater it's the
continent because they're in a right
angle triangle do you see it okay good
that's good that's progress okay if
that's 90 minus theta
I want you to now look at the original
circle the black one okay look at the
original circle the big one okay now I
want you to tell me what this angle is
equal to just focus on the original
circle ABCD is a what it's a cyclic
quadrilateral that means that the
opposite angles the opposite angles are
what they are they're not the same
they're supplementary okay that makes
this guy 90 plus theta do you agree
because that's the 180 okay now now come
to the blue circle come to the blue
circle okay that's why we had so many so
good on you
okay do you notice this guy here that 90
plus theta is an exterior angle of this
triangle do you see it ad zebb do you
see it so therefore if this is 90 plus
theta and you've got 90 here what does
that make this into your angle
it's Theta okay all right now wait a
second look we said that those two blue
angles are equal right the two blue
angles so that means they're both
thinner but we also said the two orange
angles are equal so they're both theatre
as well now look what we've created see
this Shea
here see that the what are those what is
call what's the relationship between
those they're vertically opposite but
only if this is a straight line which is
what we were trying to prove right
so because vertically opposite angles
are equal that green line I'll get rid
of these purple things now yeah you are
right you are right the green line is
really a line because you've got
vertically opposite angles